CERTAINLY AT THE
STATE DEPARTMENT.
>> Dan: X A LOT.
ALSO DEVELOPING.
A "WASHINGTON POST" IS OUT WITH
A NEW PIECE THIS WEEK CASTING
DOUBT ON CLAIMS FROM CONGRESSMAN
DEVIN NUNES AND OTHERS ABOUT
MYSTERIOUS MULTIS PROFESSOR
HAVING TIES TO WESTERN
INTELLIGENCE.
REMEMBER, AT THE CENTER OF THE
CASE AGAINST GEORGE
PAPADOPOULOS.
AND WHILE JIM COMEY CAST HIM AS
A RUSSIAN AGENT, MUELLER'S
REPORT MAKES NO SUCH CLAIM.
IF QUESTIONS ABOUT WHETHER OR
NOT THERE'S UNDISCLOSED TIES TO
THE WEST HAVE YET TO BE
ANSWERED.
IF YOU'RE TO RESPOND TO ALL OF
THIS IS RANKING MEMBER OF THE
HOUSE INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE,
REPUBLICAN CONGRESSMAN
DEVIN NUNES.
CONGRESSMAN, IT'S REALLY GREAT
TO TALK TO.
YOUR WORK ON THIS CASE.
I THINK WHEN WE LOOK BACK ON IT,
YOU WILL BE REMEMBERED FOR IT.
IF YOU'VE DONE INCREDIBLE WORK
AND I DEEPLY APPRECIATE IT.
HAVING SAID THAT, THE CORE OF
THE CONSPIRACY THEORY AGAINST
DONALD TRUMP HAS BEEN THAT HE
HAD SOME TIES TO THE RUSSIAN
GOVERNMENT, RELAYED INFORMATION
TO TRUMP CAMPAIGN MEMBER GEORGE
PAPADOPOULOS, AND THAT SET OFF
THIS TIDE OF THE FBI
INVESTIGATORY TRAIL.
BUT CONGRESSMAN, BOB MUELLER,
AFTER MILLIONS OF DOLLARS, 500
SEARCH WARRANTS, MULTIPLE FBI
AGENTS INTERVIEWING PEOPLE,
MAKES NO SUCH CLAIM IN HIS
REPORT.
HE SAID THERE ARE RUSSIAN
CONNECTIONS.
THAT'S FAR DIFFERENT THAN HIM
BEING A RUSSIAN AGENT.
WHAT ARE WE MISSING HERE?
>> YOU KNOW, DAN, THERE'S ALWAYS
THIS SAYING WHERE THERE'S SMOKE
THERE'S FIRE, IN THIS CASE
THERE'S NOT EVEN SMOKE.
THERE'S NOT EVEN ANY ASHES.
THE FACT THAT JOSEPH MIFSUD, A
MULTIS DIPLOMAT BEFORE HE WAS A
PROFESSOR, SEEN IN PICTURES OF
PEOPLE LIKE BORIS JOHNSON.
LEADING TALKS AT NATO.
HE IS INVOLVED WITH MANY U.S.
AGENCIES, INCLUDING THE
STATE DEPARTMENT AND THE FBI AND
LET'S JUST TOP IT OFF WITH THIS.
IN EARLY 2017, AT THE HOUSE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE IS
BEGINNING OUR INVESTIGATION,
JUST STEPS AWAY FROM THAT
INVESTIGATION.
JOSEPH MIFSUD WAS GUESS WHERE?
IN THE U.S. CAPITOL AT THE
INVITATION OF THE STATE
DEPARTMENT OR A GROUP ASSOCIATED
WITH THE STATE DEPARTMENT.
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS WERE THERE.
SO LOOK, THE FACT THAT JOSEPH
MIFSUD KNOWS SOME RUSSIANS,
YEAH, I THINK THAT'S VERY
LIKELY.
THE FACT THAT MUELLER IGNORES
CERTAIN DOCUMENTS THAT HE
ACTUALLY USES.
IF HE USES PIECES OF NEWS
STORIES AND WHAT I CALL THE
MUELLER DOSSIER, THE MUELLER
REPORT.
IN THOSE SAME NEWS REPORTS, DAN,
YOU HAVE EVIDENCE IN THE NEWS
REPORT WHERE THEY CALL HIM AND
HIS WRITERS THAT THEY THOUGHT
WERE GOOD ENOUGH TO USE TO MAKE
ONE POINT.
THEY DON'T USE THE FACT THAT
THOSE WRITERS CLAIM HE WAS A
WESTERN INTELLIGENCE ASSET.
THIS WHOLE MIFSUD THING HAS
STUNK FOR A LONG TIME.
IT MAKES NO SENSE.
I HAVE NO IDEA WHETHER OR NOT HE
IS A RUSSIAN ASSET OR A WESTERN
INTELLIGENCE ASSET FOR A DOUBLE
AGENT OR WHAT.
ALL I KNOW IS THAT AFTER
$40 MILLION, WE STILL DON'T KNOW
ANY MORE THAN WE KNEW BEFORE,
AND THIS IS SUPPOSEDLY THE GUY
THAT KNEW ABOUT THE CLINTON
EMAIL.
>> Dan: CONGRESSMAN, ONE OF
THE SUSPICIOUS PIECES I FOUND IN
"THE WASHINGTON POST" REPORT,
THEY EMPHASIZE THAT LENGTH,
MIFSUD'S EFFORTS TO CULTIVATE
RELATIONSHIPS WITH RUSSIA.
IF HE WAS A RUSSIAN ASSET, THEN
WHY IS HE CULTIVATING -- YOU
UNDERSTAND HOW THAT DOESN'T MAKE
ANY SENSE.
ON ONE HAND ARE TELLING US HE IS
THE KEY FIGURE IN A RUSSIAN
EXCHANGE OF INFORMATION WITH THE
TRUMP TEAM TO WIN AND ELECTION
AND ON THE OTHER HAND IN
"THE WASHINGTON POST" YOUR
REPORTING THAT HE STILL TAKING
TRIPS TO RUSSIA TRYING TO
INGRATIATE HIMSELF TO PEOPLE.
BOTH OF THOSE STORIES CAN'T BE
TRUE AT THE SAME TIME.
>> THE OTHER WEIRD THING ABOUT
THIS, DAN, IS YOU HAVE THE
MAINSTREAM MEDIA, WHO GOT THIS
TOTALLY WRONG.
THEY WERE WRONG ABOUT THE HOAX.
IF YOU TALK ABOUT IT ON YOUR
SHOW ALL THE TIME, YOU'VE
WRITTEN A BOOK ON IT, THE MANY
PEOPLE THAT YOU JUST HAD ON
BEFORE US HAVE TALKED ABOUT
THIS, WHEN THEY JUST GOING TO
GIVE IT UP?
THESE ARE RUSSIAN HOAXES.
WHAT ON EARTH IS
"THE WASHINGTON POST" DOING
JUMPING BACK INTO THE RUSSIA
HOAX WATER?
AND I THINK WHAT THEY FOUND AS
THEY LOOK FOOLISH AGAIN.
BECAUSE LOOK, THE ONLY GUY THAT
WE KNOW THAT HAS SAID FOR SURE
THAT MIFSUD IS A RUSSIAN ASSET
IS GUESS WHO?
JAMES COMEY.
JUST ABOUT A MONTH AGO IN THE
PAGES OF "THE WASHINGTON POST."
SO THEN "THE WASHINGTON POST" --
THEY HAVE ALL OF THEIR
SUPPOSEDLY SOURCES THAT THEY
DON'T NAME.
IF NONE OF THIS MAKES ANY SENSE,
BUT I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY THE
MAINSTREAM MEDIA CONTINUES TO
JUMP INTO THESE WATERS.
WHY DON'T THEY ACTUALLY TRY TO
GO GET THE TRUTH?
RIGHT?
THE INTERVIEW -- THE INTERVIEW A
LADY IN THE STORY THAT AT ONE
TIME HAD AFFILIATION -- A U.K.
CITIZEN.
YOU PROBABLY KNOW THE NAME.
>> Dan: YEAH.
>> SO CLEARLY SHE KNOWS MIFSUD.
RIGHT?
THEY INTERVIEWED HER.
WHY NOT ASK HER POINT BLANK, YOU
WORK WITH THIS GUY, HE WORKED
THE STATE DEPARTMENT, YOU WORK
WITH THE FBI IN THE PAST, WHO IS
THIS GUY?
WHY WE DO NOT HAVE TWO OR THREE
OR FOUR PARAGRAPHS JUST
INTERVIEWING HER?
SHE COULD PROBABLY TELL YOU A
LOT.
MUELLER COULDN'T CALL HIM A
RUSSIAN ASSET.
>> Dan: I WANT TO GET THIS ONE
LAST QUESTION.
ALSO, WHY ISN'T THERE SOME KIND
OF DAMAGE ASSESSMENT BEING DOWN
BY THE GOVERNMENT IF A RUSSIAN
ASSET, JOSEPH MIFSUD, PALLING
AROUND WITH U.K. INTELLIGENCE,
IN THE UNITED STATES IN FEBRUARY
OF 2017.
WHERE'S THE DAMAGE ASSESSMENT AT
THIS POINT?
>> THAT'S BEEN OUR MAJOR POINT
THE WHOLE TIME.
IF MIFSUD WAS A RUSSIAN ASSET,
YOU'VE GOT THE FBI, THE
STATE DEPARTMENT, THE U.S.
CONGRESS.
ALL OF OUR ALLIES, NATO,
BORIS JOHNSON.
THEY'VE ALL BEEN COMPROMISED BY
THIS RUSSIAN ASSET, FAMOUS
RUSSIAN ASSET, JOSEPH MIFSUD.
THE FACT THAT THEY'RE NOT DOING
A DAMAGE ASSESSMENT I THINK
TELLS YOU IN THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
ALL YOU NEED TO KNOW.